There was a point when.
You know, I stood in my closet
holding a 45 caliber pistol.
And I didn't want to go back to
that.
Scott Mann is a Green Beret and a
military veteran who suffered
from severe trauma after
he returned from
Afghanistan.
He resolved never to go back to
that part of the world again.
It was a pretty dark transition, a
lot of survivor's guilt, a lot of
challenges with purpose coming out
of, you know, multiple combat tours
and really got to a place
in my life where I saw where things
were going in Afghanistan.
I saw where things were going with
with a very careerist military.
And I just didn't want to be a part
of it anymore.
The Taliban is in control
of Afghanistan and Western countries
are scrambling to get people out.
Thousands of people continue to try
and get into the airport and onto
a flight.
But as the Americans acknowledged,
while they control the airport, they
no longer control the entire
process.
In August of 2021, he received
a call from Afghan special operator
Nizam.
It was very obvious that he was in
severe duress.
He had been shot through the face,
defending a US team from an ambush.
Like this guy was, you know, the
quintessential special operator
and truly a brother.
And when he called me, he said
to me, "Sir, I'm not afraid to die.
I just don't want to die alone." And
it just that just brought me to my
core that we can that, you
know, how do I leave this guy?
How do we leave this guy?
I ended up calling a couple of
buddies who were still on active
duty, who had fought with Nezam,
who loved him dearly.
And they were like, hell yeah,
let's do it. Let's, you know, let's
get him out. And and then
I called a congressman.
That was also that's also a Green
Beret and a couple other
folks. And
we started putting a plan together.
We moved him through the city
in a dingy old taxicab, and his
phone was like on 10% power.
And, you know, we're thinking we're
going to lose him.
He is wanted by the Taliban and
he's going to be, you know, swinging
by a lamppost by nightfall.
So we had one last
play, and it was an email
and a phone number to a diplomat on
the inside named JP that
we had been given.
So out of desperation, Hail Mary,
we called that number and in just
a couple of minutes explained the
story of Nezam, how he had
taken a bullet through the face.
He paused and he said,
"You know, I was a Green Beret
before I was a diplomat."
And he goes, "Tell him to say
pineapple." So we're like screaming
pineapple into the phone, you know?
And a few minutes later,
we get a selfie of Nezam on the
other side of the wire.
And he had been pulled through.
Then my phone just started blowing
up and it
was from, you
know, old friends.
That we're going through the same
thing.
You know.
And I looked at my wife and I was
like, well,
you know, what are we going to do
here? And she's like, You know what
you have to do.
So that is how Task Force Pineapple
began.
Mann received The Reason
Foundation's 2022
Sarvis Award for Privatization,
which recognizes his extraordinary
effort in creating a volunteer
network that saved hundreds
of Afghan nationals after
the U.S. withdrawal.
When the U.S. hastily announced a
departure date from the country, it
wasn't clear what would happen to
the thousands of Afghans who had
worked directly with military
personnel during the war and thus
faced retribution from the Taliban.
I've done enough interviews on this
that I'm convinced there was not
a concrete plan.
And when I ask about a plan to the
to the men and women who were really
at the NCO level and the company
commander level, they just start
laughing.
You know, there was not a plan for
the evacuation.
Man and his team developed a system
for helping those who had worked
with U.S. forces to navigate
their way to Abbey Gate, the main
security checkpoint at the Kabul
airport.
Then they recruited military
personnel known as conductors to
pick them out from the crowd.
And they would look for a green chem
light from the conductor
when they saw the green chem light.
They would hold up a symbol of the
pineapple on their phone.
And then the conductor, who
had a baseball card with picture and
numbering party, would call out
their name, would ask for their name
and number in the party.
If it was correct, they would pull
their party and count them out, put
them in highlight's trucks and drive
them across the airfield for
processing.
And so that became our
underground railroad.
And we put it in full swing for
about a 72 hour period
to move hundreds of Afghans
through the wire.
Scott continues to advocate for the
thousands of Afghans who worked with
U.S. forces but are still in
hiding within the country with
no escape plan.
We had 6000 people
on our manifest who were in safe
houses. We had 20
kids born in safe houses
post explosion.
One of the things I'm probably, I
guess, most proud
of is that we were
able to raise enough
revenue to keep our
6000 person manifest
to get them through the winter.
And some of them didn't make it.
Some of them were assassinated,
hunted, and killed.
And there are hundreds
of veterans, not just in Pineapple,
but in a lot of these other groups
as well. They are in a moral
quandary where they are literally
the singular lifeline to these
families, to these partners who have
no other recourse.
They don't know how they can move on
with their lives, you
know, and that's a real, real
problem that's going to have to be
addressed.